jack oder genau richtig ein
gesundheitspolitiker fordert jetzt die
absage des st keiner weiß dabei ist der
selbst karneval ist ja das fordert der
chef des gesundheitsausschusses im
bundestag erwin rüddel das lang drückten
sich ja bund und länder vor dieser
unpopulären entscheidung ja ja oder
genau richtig darüber diskutiere ich
jetzt mit erwin rüddel und ich möchte
auch jemanden begrüßen dem solche
entscheidungen wahrscheinlich besonders
weh tun würden nämlich henning
krautmacher frontmann der berühmten
höhner herzlich willkommen herr rütteln
sie sind selbst gerade gesagt
begeisterter karnevalist was bewegt sie
sich jetzt was bewegt sie jetzt dazu die
absage zu fordern
also man sieht im moment dass die
infektionszahlen wieder steigen
wir haben alle die bilder im kopf von 1
berg von ich jetzt vom ballermann ich
bin der festen überzeugung
abstandsregeln und in verbindung mit
alkohol das ist kaum umsetzbar und
deshalb halte ich es für sinnvoll dass
wir jetzt in diesem jahr für den
november den karneval absagen zur
sicherheit zum schutz der bevölkerung
aber auch zum schutz des ehrenamtes und
auch zum schutz unseres schönen
rheinischen brauchtums das halte ich für
sehr wichtig und diese verantwortung
dürfen wir auch nicht allein den
vereinen übertragen hier ist die politik
gefordert und ich denke dass hier die
drei bundesländer im rheinland pfalz
nordrhein westfalen saarland gemeinsam
eine entscheidung treffen müssen den
karneval für den november abzusagen dann
die entwicklungen abzuwarten und ich bin
als karnevalist optimist und ich hoffe
dass es schneller geht mit dem impfstoff
und das wird vielleicht noch zwei drei
wochen karneval in 20 21 feiern können
krautmacher angenommen im november darf
die karawane nicht weiterziehen wie geht
es ihnen damit
das problem haben wir jetzt schon seit
einigen monaten dabei etwas vorweg
schicken
als ich gestern angerufen worden bin und
mir erzählt worden ist das rüttelt den
general absagen will hat das bei mir ein
ganz anderes bild aus dass jetzt gerade
nach dem monolog habe ich festgestellt
erreger ist ja ein nachfolger oder jack
und seine befürchtungen sind ja nicht
einfach aus der luft gegriffen
ich bin dabei in das wir abwarten müssen
ich denke es ist in der tat jetzt noch
zu früh den karneval komplett abzusagen
gestern habe ich auf diese aussage
reagierte braucht der kerne wall ist
nicht absehbar das fest dass gerade weil
es war war immer ein fest dass aus dem
volk heraus geboren wurde und wir hatten
ja selbst beim golfkrieg damals die
situation dass die jecken dann gesagt
haben die träume die du hast musst du
nicht grieche auf hochdeutsch die tränen
die du lachst brauchst du nicht zu
weinen und der karneval ist gefeiert
worden
gefährlich wird die ganze sache immer
dann wenn es aus den fugen gerät wenn
man das nicht in irgendeiner form
reglementiert wenn die menschen sich
nicht an die abstandsregeln halten und
dann ähnliche bilder gezeigt werden wie
wir sie eben auch in dieser sendung
gesehen haben also da bin ich dabei aber
die hoffnung stirbt immer zum schluss
der karnevalsauftakt findet ja im freien
statt am elften im elften wir stehen im
engen kontakt mit den
karnevalsgesellschaften nicht den wir ja
auch viele verträge haben wir einigen
uns auch da wir sind da auch zu
kompromissen bereit müssen weiter wir
sind da irgendwo eine eine große
gemeinschaft die alle nur das beste
wollen und haben natürlich die hoffnung
dass ein impfstoff gefunden wird wenn
dem nicht so ist dann müssen wir nach
den ferien erst mal sehen was passiert
im november und absagen der offiziellen
absage kommt ich will es mir noch nicht
vorstellen und ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass man auch hier kreativ wird
wie es auch in diesem tag passiert ich
komme gerade von einem konzert gestern
abend haben ein großes open air in bonn
in der rheinau gespielt die leute haben
sich
alle an die regeln gehalten also das
muss auch für den karneval machen würde
warum kann man mit dieser entscheidung
nicht noch ein bisschen warten sowie
herr krautmacher das gerade angesprochen
hat also die die vereine sind alle in
den vorbereitungen die vereine haben
verträge mit künstlern geschlossen
die künstler brauchen orientierung die
vereine brauchen orientierung und als
gesundheitspolitiker ist mir zu
mindestens bewusst dass also wenn
gefeiert wird man eine riesengroße
verantwortung eingeht und diese
verantwortung darf man nicht allein beim
ehrenamt abladen und auch die
wirtschaftlichen risiken die die vereine
eingehen oder eingegangen sind
die müssen aufgefangen werden die können
nur aufgefangen werden wenn von seiten
des staates
der karneval abgesagt wird für die
künstler gibt es rettungsschirme für die
solo selbstständigen gibt es
rettungsschirme für die vereine gibt es
keine rettungsschirme ich weiß mir ist
bewusst die vereine brauchen die
künstler und die künstler brauchen die
vereine aber wir brauchen auch eine
starke struktur bei den vereinen damit
die auch in zukunft karneval feiern
können künstler engagieren können
und deshalb denke ich ist es ein kleiner
beitrag im november auf den karneval zu
verzichten zumindest sohn von verzichten
wie wir ihn bisher kennen
ich habe ja auch differenziert zwischen
saal karneval und straßenkarneval denke
da auch an die aero sohle ich denke an
hallen die umluft anlagen haben also das
ist alles nicht so einfach man muss also
die gesundheitsaspekte sehen und wichtig
ist dass wir die verantwortung nicht
beim ehrenamt abladen und dass wir unser
schönes brauchtum pflegen dafür brauchen
wir die vereine dafür brauchen wir die
künstler und wir brauchen wir eine
lösung und mein vorschlag ist
wir probieren das mal mit der absage für
november um kräfte gemeinsam zu sammeln
für januar februar 21 und dann in der
hoffnung dass das dann im herbst zu 21
wieder ganz normal
herr krautmacher wären gerade gehört es
geht um existenzen sollte jetzt im
november der karneval abgesagt werden
die höhner sind seit jahrzehnten fester
bestandteil des carnevals geht es dann
auch für sie an die existenz oder können
sie das gut noch abfangen bis das jahr
2021 dann startet wer es ist jetzt sehr
unterschiedlich gelagert die höhle haben
das große glück ersten schon seit vielen
vielen jahren geschäft zu sein und was
noch viel wichtiger ist die räder hatten
das glück und das ist wirklich die
ausnahme
ein paar hits landen zu können und wären
gut wirtschaftet dann kann man auch eine
gewisse zeit überbrücken
aber das leben und auch insbesondere
kanada besteht ja nicht nur aus der
musikgruppe hören also das sind auch
ganz ganz viele sehr junge besser sind
nicht nur musikgruppen da sind tanzkorps
oster sind einzelkünstler die da auf den
redner
allesamt sind ja davon betroffen ich bin
ja gar nicht so weit weg vom von ihnen
würde ich habe etwas position und ich
gebe zu bedenken es gibt ja noch eine
ganze reihe von leuten die auch ideen
haben ich weiß dass die gesellschaften
aber auch das festkomitee wie man so
schön sagt den engen austausch auch mit
dem fest mit dem präsidenten mit
christoph kuckelkorn
wir haben ja erst mal pläne in der
schublade welche planen sie daher ziehen
das ist abhängig von der entwicklung und
ich bin sehr gespannt wie sich das ganze
jetzt entwickelt und mir ist es einfach
auch für den november noch zu früh zu
sagen wie wir sagen einfach rigoros ab
aber herr kaufmann 1 haben wir ja
gesehen in letzter zeit wenn ich da
einen haken nach alkohol hallen und
sicherheitsabstände das ist jetzt nichts
was wirklich gut funktioniert oder du
hast dich jetzt sollte man vordergründig
so annehmen aber ich habe eine andere
erfahrung jetzt aktuell gemacht wir
haben eine ganze reihe von autokino
konzerten gespielt da ist wahl und
natürlich tabu weil die fahrer gar nicht
trinken dürfen
und das ganze wurde jetzt abgelöste von
von open-air-veranstaltungen wir haben
im altehrwürdigen ehemaligen millowitsch
theater sogar ein konzert wie gehen die
menschen halten sich an die regeln und
ich weiß auch dass ein deutsches
phänomen ist
wir haben hier was keine schlechten
erfahrungen gemacht wir haben auch so
genannte biergarten konzerte gebracht wo
menschen den sechsergruppen an einer
solchen bierzeltgarnituren und die
glaube ich sitzen
und da ist auch das ein oder andere
gläschen kölsch oder erst einmal
getrunken worden aber es ist niemand
über die stränge geschlagen und ich habe
auch hier die große hoffnung dass die
jecken die karnevalisten sich an diese
regeln halten wollen weil sie wollen ja
ihr traditionsfest feiern und ich sag's
doch weil ich bin da auch beim fest
kommentierte bach bei der gesellschaft
ich würde es nicht so gerne dem zufall
überlassen also ich fand es schon toll
wenn man das ganze wirklich fest ordnend
ein bisschen begleiten könnte alkohol
und trotzdem abstand das geht schon sie
glauben nicht daran
also ich glaub da also die karnevalisten
sind besondere menschen also da bin ich
also mit gemerkt macher einer meinung
die wissen auch mit verantwortung
umzugehen
das sind vernünftige menschen aber ich
habe auch die sorge dass also vielleicht
nach dem 10
bier vielleicht die vernunft etwas
nachlässt also ich habe die sorge und
man hat ja kennt ja die bilder und wenn
es nachher heißt der karneval ist die
ursache dafür dass wir eine zweite oder
dritte welle in deutschland haben dann
haben wir den karneval keine gefahr
getan dann haben wir unser brauchtum
beschädigt und deshalb für ist meine
meinung
besonnenheit zu wahren und den vereinen
und das sind nicht nur die feste
öffnenden vereine in köln sondern um
köln herum gibt es tausende von kleinen
vereinen die orientierung brauchen die
auch gern mit den künstlern
zusammenarbeiten
und deshalb glaube ich kann man sich
also nicht auf das fest ordnende komitee
in köln allein verlassen sondern das ist
wichtig dass also von der politik
offiziell für november
der karneval abgesagt wird ich denke man
muss das so machen dass also noch
möglichkeiten haltungen und ich denke
das gibt auch dann zeit und im
januar/februar vielleicht wenn wir dann
wie gesagt ich hab eben gesagt bin
optimist vielleicht einen impfstoff
haben und wir dann zumindest im februar
wieder ganz normal karneval feiern
können